if you take the modern world where
people are trying to teach you
how to come in and trade actively in
stocks
what's up tim sykes millionaire
mentoring trader here i want to teach
you i want to
help you well i regard that as roughly
equivalent to trying to induce a bunch
of young people to start off on heroin
we're here to support you i want to see
you on this jet with us next time
it's awesome and you can totally do it
you've enjoyed this right now you love
guts you just don't know it it is really
stupid
and when you're already rich to make
your money by encouraging people to get
rich
by trading if you're a millionaire why
sell a course
then there are people on the tv and they
say
i have this book it will teach you how
to make 300 a year
the millionaire booklet's going to give
you eight steps and guess what
all you have to do is pay for shipping
first you're going to pay shipping and
handling
and it's ridiculous the people who do
this all day
think they're useful citizens but they
mislead you on purpose
and and i get tired of it
and i don't think it's right you're
giving away your free book you're just
trying to sell me stuff
of course i am i have no shame i have no
guilt
i have no hesitation